they created their own de facto
state carved out of parts of syria and
iraq
and ruled in a most brutal way
justifying their actions with their
own interpretation of islam
two years ago president trump declared
isil had been defeated
that after a long military operation
some of it human rights campaigners say
also carried out in a brutal manner
involving kurdish fighters
the iraqi military american special
forces
and u.s bombardment from the air
now their former capital raqqa lies in
ruins
but experts say isil may be slowly
rebuilding themselves
in the deserts of syria and what we've
witnessed in central syria in particular
is a robust and growing isis campaign
that is applying pressure on key
military and oil infrastructure that is
actually forcing the russians the regime
and the iranians to respond and try to
figure out how to stabilize the security
situation
is such talk alarmist not according to
the un's special envoy for syria
gare pedersen we should actually be
worried about what we see
as increased daesh activities in the
desert and in certain other areas in
syria
and i have appealed before as you know
to the members of the security council
that we need a collaborative effort
to fight the terrorists that are still
active in syria
and without that collaborative effort
i'm afraid we could fail once again
on top of this there's another problem
related to isil that the world is not
confronting
there are thousands of prisoners some of
them foreign fighters
but mainly women and children being held
in camps in northeast syria
in the largest camp al hull there are
nearly thirty
thousand children the conditions are
grim
they risk being alienated and further
radicalized
james bay's al jazeera at the united
nations
well marwan kabalan is head of policy
analysis at the arab centre for research
and policy studies he's joining us here
in doha
by skype good to have you with us here
on al jazeera one thing i just want to
get is some context for you if i could
from you if i could
is isil still regarded as a single
entity or is it more than ideology that
armed groups choose to fight under
no i mean the simple answer to that
question rob perhaps is that
isil and the likes organizations have
always been
i mean the most important i mean aspect
of them is that the idea the ideology
which
drives them uh in the first place
if you if you remember this war on
terror the united states started
actually 20 years ago after the
september 11 attacks
on new york and and washington and it
started as a war against al qaeda
and then against isil and probably in
the coming years we're going to see
a new organization with a different name
all of these organizations actually have
always been
consistent in the sense that
the very uh the causes which have led to
the emergence in the first place must be
dealt with
if we really want to defeat them once
and for
all and as long as these causes are not
dealt with i think we are going to keep
seeing them
coming back time and and again
so now i'm really not surprised that
isil is making a comeback in syria and
in iraq
we have seen a rise or an increase in
the activities
of isil in the in both countries
the united states as we all know has
declared victory against isil in
2019 it has declared victory against
al-qaeda i mean before that
but i just said uh rob before
you really need to deal with the
withdrawal causes
uh which is leading in fact to the rise
of
isil of al-qaeda and like-minded
organizations you need to deal with the
ideology we
you need to deal actually which with
with the idea
and with the circumstances which are
leading i mean to these organizations
coming back
and again uh every every uh
everyone let me ask you about those
causes then what are the circumstances
specifically in syria but also in iraq
that are allowing
isil and on groups relating themselves
to isil to begin to
strengthen again marginalization of
an important part of both iraqi and
syrian societies are
actually making parts of
of these societies which feel that
unjustice have been
actually done to them to make them
sympathize with isil on one hand and
also sectarianism in the region is
another factor
that we need to deal with the rise of
iranian influence in the region over the
past few years since the us invasion of
iraq in 2003 in fact has led to
um to the rise of shiite influence in
the region that is driving actually
parts of sydney societies in both syria
and iraq
uh into seeing isil as uh as an
organization that probably
is representing them somehow although i
mean that
the war against isil has led to the to
further destruction for these sunni
communities
but sectarianism marginalizations of
important parts of syria and iraqi
societies are leading actually i mean to
to the rise of isil one more time and
are
the the latin causes behind the
continuation of
uh like-minded organizations uh
in in in both countries always good to
get your thoughts on this marwan kabalan
we appreciate you joining us and al
jazeera thank you very much indeed
thank you